so i went to a bartending school i ended
up doing a few shifts at this bar in
london uh which was a lot of fun i had a
white tuxedo and everything yep tom
holland takes his job very seriously
even if it means he secretly has to work
as a bartender to prepare
hey kid a little young for a bartender
aren't you a little old for prom aren't
you while promoting his latest film
uncharted with co-star mark wahlberg the
25 year old actor goes into detail with
siriusxm's jessica shaw about his
undercover gig one of my favorite things
about what we do for a living is when
you get given the opportunity to learn a
new skill for a reason other than you
just want to give it a go so i went to a
bartending school i ended up doing a few
shifts at this bar in london
which was a lot of fun so i had a white
tuxedo and everything i would go in
there and take the bartender's clothes
and be in there undercover tom's
favorite drink to make i like making an
espresso martini shaken not stirred
but the spiderman no way home star says
his bartending gig didn't last very long
as word spread around town and like
people started figuring out that oh yeah
apparently tom holland is bartending at
this bar
then the general manager started
figuring it out and then eventually i
sort of got kicked out i have been back
to the bar
but it's a little bit of a rocky
relationship at the minute but in
uncharted tom does way more than mix up
some cocktails
when eti caught up with the british
actor he talked about how his role as
spider-man prepared him for the
action-packed role i've been very lucky
with my stunt team that i work with on
spider-man they have given me such an
incredible education in the world of
stunts in dealing with wire work and
designing sequences to be more effective
and also more naturalistic so i have a
great knowledge of how that all works
but then again with spider-man i've
always been able to wear a mask so there
are elements of you know you're able to
disguise certain things and and cg can
enhance things here and there whereas
with nathan drake in this film we really
had to push the limits of what we could
do practically and when tom isn't busy
going undercover or starring in major
blockbusters he's spending quality time
with his girlfriend zendaya i just feel
very lucky on wednesday the couple was
out and about in nyc here's z and t
holding hands while leaving a hotel
together both of course bringing their
fashion a game zendaya is the one at
serving looks she is the one to go for
for tips the two seem to be enjoying
their downtime together since the
december release of their film
spider-man no way home as they should be
[Music]